cuál es el estado de los océanos hoy en
día
hola que tal buenas tardes bueno los
océanos la realidad es que hoy en día a
nivel global están muy amenazados
sin duda uno de los principales amenazas
es el humano las personas que habitamos
este planeta a través de nuestras
actividades que le generan muchísimo
daño al océano y a sus ecosistemas no
este día es muy importante parar para
recordar la importancia que tienen los
océanos para la vida en el planeta
porque literalmente nuestra vida depende
de océanos sanos y también recordarnos
sobre la responsabilidad que tenemos a
la hora de protegernos no una de las
grandes amenazas que tienen los océanos
es que están muy desprotegidos por
ejemplo cuando hablamos de aguas
internacionales que representa casi el
50 por ciento de la superficie del
planeta sólo el 1% está protegido es
decir que casi la la mitad del planeta
está totalmente desprotegida del avance
de las industrias destructivas que les
generan muchísimo daño como por ejemplo
la industria del petróleo offshore la
pesca la sobrepesca la nueva amenaza de
la minería de fondo marino y sin duda
es necesario poder avanzar en la
protección y frenar a estas a estas
actividades tan nocivas que le generan
tanto daño porque realmente necesitamos
océanos años piscina como tratamos
nuestras aguas cuáles son los mayores
daños que los seres humanos le hacemos
bueno como te comentaba un poco recién
hoy en muchos lugares del mundo se está
avanzando con actividades que son muy
nocivas y que en la situación mundial
que estamos viviendo de emergencia
climática sin duda deberíamos estar
frenando como por ejemplo es el avance
de la industria petrolera en muchos
lugares del mundo en el mar no nos
olvidemos que los océanos son los
principales mitigadores del cambio
climático como vos recién decías y
citando a las naciones unidas- los
océanos no sólo generan casi el 80 por
ciento del oxígeno que se libera a la
atmósfera pero también capturan carbono
de la atmósfera son los principales
mitigadores del cambio climático le
proveen alimento y trabajo a millones de
personas en el mundo regulan el clima
regulan los los ciclos del agua y todas
estas actividades contribuyen al cambio
climático y cuando cuanto más cambio
climático tenemos cuando cuanto más sube
la temperatura del planeta peor va a ser
el estado de los océanos se acidifica le
sube la temperatura y eso hace que los
ecosistemas empiecen a degradarse y
cuando los océanos empiezan a delgada
y la vida en el planeta va a ser
prácticamente imposible piscina nos
queda poco tiempo pero no quiero dejar
de realizar de la siguiente pregunta son
los corales sumideros de carbono y como
los podemos proteger cuando nos estamos
enfrentando al calentamiento de los
océanos
sin duda hay que avanzar en
regular estas actividades que van a
profundizar el cambio climático porque
los corales en particular los afecta
muchísimo el cambio climático y además
hay que crear santuarios marinos en
todos los mares del mundo para poder
cerrar a estas áreas tan vulnerables al
impacto de las distintas actividades tan
destructivas que le generan tanto a
nuestros ecosistemas fundamentales de
nuestros océanos